SRIDHAR RAMASWAMY: Hello.
Welcome, everybody.
It's always fun to have
mid-afternoon sessions
in a hot tent.
My name is Sridhar Ramaswamy.
I lead the Ads and
Commerce teams at Google.
And here with me is
Pali Bhat, the product
lead for Payments at Google.
And we're really
excited to be talking
to you about all the latest
and greatest in Android Pay.
I want to start by addressing
the elephant in the room.
There are tons of pays
that are out there.
And all of you want to
know, who's winning?
Is there a winner?
But the sad answer
is, no, not really.
There is no winner.
Legacy payment methods like
the credit card and cash
are still the dominant
payment methods
that are being used out there.
Even the most avid
technology enthusiasts
among us is
hesitant, are scared,
to leave our credit
cards and cash behind.
And the natural question
is, what's holding us back?
We thought a lot about this.
And we think there are
three big reasons for this.
The first of course,
is a big one--
is that all the mobile payment
methods are kind of limited.
Some work for the physical
contactless terminals.
Some work with all terminals.
You know, sometimes it works
in-app but not in-- not
on the mobile web.
And we're going to
talk a lot about that.
It's the unpredictability of
whether your mobile payment
method is going to work,
that makes you want to say,
no, I can't rely on
it 100% of the time.
We think the second
big reason is
that a lot of the payment
schemes that are out there
are kind of uncompelling.
You're talking about an
activity that all of us
do many times a
week, that we have
done the same way
for many, many years.
And so if you're going
to go ask humanity
to change the way that they
think about payments, what's
the value-add?
They're kind of uncompelling.
And this is something we really
do want to address as well.
And we actually think that
the uncompelling nature
of the payment solution comes
about because most payment
solutions are kind of closed.
They have a few key pieces of
functionality, and that's it.
What makes our
smartphones great,
whether it's Android or iOS, is
not just the operating system.
We like aspects of our phones
that come directly from Google.
But the fact of the matter
is what we really love,
are our apps.
It's a great functionality
that comes on.
Is that animation
the developers like
you have provided on
the core platform.
There is no comparable
thing that's
going on in mobile payments.
We think that's kind
of a big blocker.
So what do we want to do?
Today we're going to be talking
to you about all the things
that we at Android
Pay and Google
are doing to make mobile
payments better for merchants
and retailers, for
financial institutions,
but most of all for
consumers, like you and me.
We think payments should
work everywhere they're
expected to work.
They should work in a
simple and secure way.
And we think mobile
payments would be more
like a mobile payment passport
than just a mobile wallet.
And what you will
hear from us today,
is our efforts at really
making this happen.
So we want Android Pay
therefore to be everywhere
where you and I expect
it to be present.
So we're going to
talk a lot about that,
starting with how
are we going to have
Android Pay work on mobile web.
It works fine in mobile apps.
We're also going to be talking
to you about how-- I can
hear some sound from behind.
Can others hear it?
So we're also going to be
talking to you about how
Android Pay can work in other
areas, like public transit.
We have a nifty demo
coming up over there.
And also in things like ATMs.
Wherever you expect to
use payment credentials,
we think Android Pay
should be usable there.
And we'll show you
through all of this,
how we are building a set
of consistent and simple
experiences that all
users will know and love.
But one that will also come
with the security that is
the promise of mobile payments.
And finally, we also
want to share with you
what we are doing to drive
innovation in the ecosystem--
whether it is with retailers,
or with financial institutions
like banks.
Of: course the first
part being everywhere
is being geographically
everywhere.
So we're very
pleased to announce
the expansion of Android
Pay outside the US
to an international
location, which
is we went live in
the UK earlier today.
[APPLAUSE]
Pali was there last
weekend, set up
[INAUDIBLE] running transactions
with his Android phone.
You know, checking things
out for himself to make sure
that everything was fine.
We have worked
with top partners.
You see some of them here--
HSBC, Lloyd's Bank-- to make
sure that there is a lot of
acceptance for Android Pay,
and of course with lots of apps,
and lots of physical locations.
And this is only the beginning.
So I'm also pleased to announce
that we'll be launching Android
Pay very soon, over
the next few months,
in Singapore and in Australia.
We want, I know, our ambition
is to be there everywhere
Android is.
So we're going to be launching
in Singapore and Australia
soon, with many more countries
following soon after.
They're all in the works.
So we are pleased
with how much we
will be able to expand
Android Pay through the world.
Let's switch gears now
and talk a little bit
about what we have
done with Android Pay
in-app, inside apps.
We launched the Android
Pay in-app API in December.
And we've been working with
a lot of app developers
to make Android Pay be
accepted within their apps.
And we are pleased
with the results.
Top apps-- Uber, Airbnb,
Jet.com, Instacart,
and many others-- some
of which are listed here.
All support in-app
payments with Android Pay.
And the first question you're
going to ask is like, so what?
Does this make a difference?
We thought we'd show that
with one of the apps that's
adopted Android Pay, Fancy.
Fancy is a really
cool app in that you
discover crowd-curated things.
This morning I was
browsing through stuff.
You know, if you can't tell,
I drink a lot of coffee.
And I found this really
neat espresso mug
that you could get from Fancy
that a lot of other people
have liked.
Fancy adopted Android Pay in-app
and saw some pretty stunning
results.
For users that use
Android Pay within Fancy,
they found that their
conversion rate was twice
that of other payment methods,
I don't know how you folks think
about conversion rates,
but for something
like Adwords Signup, in which
a lot of Google's fortune
is dependent on, a 1%
increase in conversion rate
is cause for major celebration.
And so getting a 2x
increase in conversion rate,
on what turns out to be a
substantial volume-- 20%
of Fancy's transactions
flow through Android Pay--
is a big, big deal for Fancy.
And it's a big, big deal
for a lot of the apps
that have adopted Android Pay.
We're really pleased
with the results
that we've seen with
these and with other apps.
I'm now handing it over to Pali.
He's going to show
us a quick demo,
and also walk us through
some of the details of how
things are working.
PALI BHAT: Yeah, thanks Sridhar.
Could we switch to
WolfVision, please?
Awesome.
So I'm going to open
up my Nexus 5X device,
and I want to show you
Android Pay working inside one
of my favorite apps, Airbnb.
I love traveling and I
have a seven-year-old,
so we need to make trips
to Disneyland very,
very frequently-- as
some of you might know.
So I'm going to try and
book something for a trip
to Disneyland soon.
So let's see here.
I think I'd saved a
search here for Disney.
And by the way, this is
actually the production app,
so I want to make sure that
it's actually still available.
So let's check for availability.
Selecting here, it looks
like all of next week
is available still,
which is very nice.
Sridhar, I hope you
don't mind this.
He's a very good manager.
So the whole week--
who'll beat that?
[LAUGHTER]
So let me just save this and
try to instant book this.
And the cool thing about this is
a really beautiful experience,
right?
The one place where it
actually isn't all that great,
is payments.
So if you go in and try
to buy something, and book
a reservation,
typically it means
you have to try and like type in
your credit card details, etc.
So we worked with Airbnb
to make this much better.
So I'm going to try
to add a payment.
This is where I usually
get a screen that says,
enter your credit
card information.
Right?
And if you have Android
Pay set up on your device,
you literally have
to do nothing else.
Just pick Android Pay.
That simple.
Shows you the chooser
with Android Pay,
and shows you my Discover
Card, on there already.
And I have to do this
confirm with my fingerprint.
OK?
[APPLAUSE]
And you can see that Android
Pay is already selected here.
And the next time I come in
I don't even have to do this.
Right?
You automatically can
check out, and you're done.
So really, really
sweet experience.
I personally love it.
OK, so, let me switch
back to the presentation
if you don't mind.
So whenever I'm
presenting with Sridhar,
I'm always wondering
where do I stand, right?
Because standing here
seems like a bad deal.
Maybe I should stand here.
SRIDHAR RAMASWAMY: There you go.
[LAUGHTER]
PALI BHAT: So, what I wanted
to share with you is of course,
we've got this amazing
integration with Airbnb.
We've done the same kind
of integration with Uber.
All of these top apps, right?
But how can every
single developer
take advantage of Android Pay?
We want to make it
really, really simple.
So we worked with a number
of top payment processors.
I mean, you can
just see this list.
It's everybody from
Braintree to Stripe to Adyen.
we've got CyberSource-- everyone
integrated into Android Pay.
So that adding in Android
Pay if you're a developer,
is really, really simple.
In fact, if you're an integrator
with Braintree or Stripe,
literally less than
10 lines of code
that you can drop in
into your Android app
and enable Android
Pay for your users.
So that's very, very awesome.
We've also done more.
We've opened up our API--
the Android Pay in-app
API-- to all Android Developers
selling physical goods
or services.
So you can go to
this URL and start
integrating right away,
regardless of who your payment
processor is.
So it's very exciting for us.
But this is not the whole
story with mobile checkouts.
Tell us more, I'll hand
it back to Sridhar.
SRIDHAR RAMASWAMY:
Thank you, Pali.
It's really cool
that in-app payments
have been-- did we rush past?
PALI BHAT: Ah, I
might have actually
just gone right past one thing.
SRIDHAR RAMASWAMY:
Can you press,
can I press back on this?
PALI BHAT: Yeah.
Can you go back one slide?
Because I just want
to show you one more
cool thing which we snuck
in at the last minute.
SRIDHAR RAMASWAMY: There you go.
PALI BHAT: And
here's the cool part.
You must have heard
during the keynote
earlier this morning about
Android Instant Apps.
What Android Instand Apps are
is this really cool technology
that lets you stream
an app to your phone.
So don't worry about
installing anything.
You just stream the app
by clicking on a link.
And you get the full
native experience
on your device, which
is like, really awesome.
Now that full native experience
wouldn't be as awesome
if you had to start typing in
all your credit card details
to complete your payment.
So what we did is work
with the Android team
to enable Android Pay
with an Instant Apps.
So I want to share with you a
little bit of this experience.
Maybe I want to like, touch
this, and you'll see B&H Photo.
I do a search for
a camera and you
can see that the link
literally streams the B&H Photo
app to my phone.
I can pick my camera,
check out, and then you
get the exact same
experience I showed you
within an installed app.
Right?
So absolutely cool.
And gives you a complete
experience right in place,
and it's streamed to your phone.
This is something that we're
very, very excited about
and we expect more
and more developers
to take advantage of this--
to reach more users who have
chosen not to install your app.
But you can still get to
them using an instant app.
Give them the same
great experience.
The user doesn't have
to do anything else.
If Android Pay is set up on
the device, it will just work.
Right?
So again, something
that we're very, very--
SRIDHAR RAMASWAMY:
And the camera's
going to show up at your
place by drone, instantly?
PALI BHAT: That would
be actually very cool.
But we will talk about how
things can show up soon.
Here you go.
So Sridhar will show us
more about mobile checkouts.
SRIDHAR RAMASWAMY: So
it's cool that they
can solve the problem of in-app
checkouts-- make it easier,
make it streamlined,
make it secure.
But the fact of the
matter is, a lot of us
spend a lot of
time on mobile web.
The time spent is skews
more towards mobile apps.
The fact of the
matter is, something
like half of all transactions
happen on mobile web.
But mobile web does not
have any of the support
that in-apps have had.
It's a different
programming model.
And the result is
that you and I are
stuck with really long payment
forms, and it's really long,
you know, details forms,
that we have to fill out
very slowly on tiny keyboards.
And it doesn't work that well.
We give up pretty often.
Conversion rates are pretty low.
So we took a baby step last year
and were stunned by the results
that we saw.
We did something that we call
Chrome Payments Autofill.
It's a small idea.
Take your Google credentials,
your Google payment credentials
that you put into Android Pay,
that you have put into Google
Play, and have it be
available for form fill-out
on mobile web.
Again, for users that actually
used Payment Autofill,
you know for check
out, the merchants
saw a 25% increase
in conversion rate.
Again, a staggering
number where wins
come in half, and quarter,
and single digit percentages.
And while this is cool, the
larger problem still remains.
You still have to fill
out other details,
go through a longish
checkout forms.
Of course that dreaded
user ID and password.
I don't know about
you, but I have
a ton of passwords stored in
the Password Manager on Chrome.
I have a spreadsheet full
of user IDs and passwords
that like I have to figure
out what to do with-- it just
keeps growing longer.
And we really need to be able
to do a whole lot better.
So what if I were to tell
you that you as a merchant
will be able to create an
experience for your consumer
that's going to be
simple and secure using
tokenized credentials, and
really make these long checkout
forms and the crazy drop-offs
a thing of the past.
And what if you,
as a consumer, also
were able to see
all your mobile web
transactions at the
same place, along
with your in-store and
in-app transactions-- the way
you can do with
Android Pay today.
We think that would
be pretty cool.
And so we are thrilled
to announce something
we call PaymentRequest
working with the Chrome theme.
And standardizing across all
browsers, to really simplify
mobile checkout.
It provides developers,
and retailers obviously,
the simple tools that
they need to create
a great mobile payment
experience on mobile web.
And this way, users have
a consistent experience
regardless of whether they
transact inside an app
or on the mobile web.
And Pali is going to show us
more about how this works.
PALI BHAT: Awesome.
If you can switch to
the Wolf Vision, again.
This is an API we're very
excited about, because it's
an open standardized API.
I'm going to show how it
works within a website.
So open up a website in
Chrome, and it turns out
to be a little store that
we built for ourselves so we
can order branded gear.
And as you can tell, I love
like wearing branded t-shirts,
with Android Pay
on them usually.
SRIDHAR RAMASWAMY: Always gray?
PALI BHAT: Always gray,
unfortunately yes.
I'm very bland in
my taste of color.
So I'm going to go in and
shop for some t-shirts.
As you can tell, we have
some cool YouTube t-shirts.
we also have just
plain Google t-shirts.
But because I'm
boring, I'm just going
to pick Android Pay again.
It's going to pick an
Android Pay t-shirt,
I'm going to add it to cart.
OK?
And as I add it to
cart, this is usually
like the portion
of the experience
that you dread when you're
on a mobile website.
And I've tried
checking out before,
and it literally is multiple
pages, filling out everything
from your billing
address, shipping address,
including your credit
card information.
Chrome Autofill really
helps you with that.
But what PaymentRequest does,
is help you skip all of this
and get that same experience
that you saw with in-apps.
So what I'm going to do
now is actually show you
the checkout experience.
So I'm going to hit checkout.
Did you notice how
quickly that came up?
So that's the full
native experience
showing up in a website with
Android Pay just working.
OK?
So I'm going to hit "Pay."
And again, I have to
confirm with my fingerprint.
OK?
And you can see my Bank
of America MasterCard
there, that I'm going
to use for my purchase.
And it's just that simple.
OK?
I'm done.
And notice, I also got a
notification right away
from the store, which I
can open up and actually
see within my Bank of America.
Right under the Bank of America
card, in the Android Pay app,
you see all of the transactions
that I've made as well.
And you see some of the
transactions that are made
[INAUDIBLE]
[APPLAUSE]
SRIDHAR RAMASWAMY:
We should notice
that Pali did the
same thing here
that he did for the
in-app checkout.
He just unlocked the phone.
No pins, nothing else.
It just works
seamlessly, which is
what is cool about this
vision that we're driving.
PALI BHAT: So it's
very exciting for us.
But of course, these APIs always
require one critical thing
for them to be successful--
and that's all of you.
Right?
And we want to make sure that we
have a set of partners testing
this API with us, and testing
the experience with us,
so we could really
make it magical.
So I'm very pleased
to announce that we
have a really awesome
set of partners
already signed up to
beta test PaymentRequest.
And we also have folks
like Shopify and Jet.com
adding in Android Pay into
this experience as well.
So very, very exciting for us.
So with that, I'm going to
switch gears a little bit,
and talk about a
critical use case
for playing with the phone.
And this is transit.
Transit is something that
users in major cities,
like London, do at
least twice a day,
and sometimes many
more times a day.
So if there's ever anything
that both meets and exceeds
the toothbrush test, if
you will, it's transit.
Right?
So we're very, very excited
to showcase the Android Pay
experience for transit.
And we've done
that in partnership
with one of the leaders in
contactless payments, Transport
for London.
OK?
Now if you don't know,
Transport for London
completes 13 million
journeys daily
for Londoners across
tube, rail, and bus.
So it's absolutely huge volumes.
Now what if you could actually
create an experience that
was just a little bit
faster and more convenient
for all of these
Londoners taking TFL?
And so we want to show you what
we worked on with the TFL team.
And it's been an
incredible partnership.
To demonstrate it, I'm going
to direct your attention
to the left there--
to some TFL gates
that we've actually
got from London.
It's absolutely cool.
These are the real deal.
And what I'm going
to demonstrate to you
is an experience--
is an experience that
has the exact same thing that
Londoners are using daily.
Right?
Now the only thing
we've done here
that's a little
bit more custom, is
we've showcased an
experience that's
going to be rolling out
over the next few months.
And by the end of
the year, we should
have it, which shows you
are truly amazing experience
in terms of how the receipts
show up with Android Pay
and want to demonstrate
that to you as well.
So we're very
excited to do this.
But without further
ado, I'm going
to enter through
one station and then
exit through the other station.
And so you should
be able to see me
entering through the Paddington
Station, I think this is.
So if you, [INAUDIBLE], if you
can just focus on the phone
here so folks can see it.
OK, great.
And so I'm going to-- no need
to open my app, nothing else.
Literally all I need to
do, tap, and I've just
paid with my Lloyd's MasterCard.
Absolutely incredible.
[APPLAUSE]
PALI BHAT: Now I think you saw
how fast that experience was.
And I personally experienced
this when I was in London.
So I'm going to tap again.
It's that simple.
And it truly is faster
than the experience
that you actually can get
using other forms of payment.
So we're very
excited about this.
And I'm going to show you
the rest of the experience
on the Wolf Vision, if
you don't mind switching.
So the first thing that I'm
going to call your attention to
is what the receipts show up as.
So I'm going to go to my
Lloyd's Bank MasterCard.
Notice that I actually got
two notifications here-- one
for entering in the
Paddington Station
and other for
exiting in Victoria.
OK?
Really Cool and I'm going
to just go into one of those
and it shows you exactly
where my journey was.
So we're very,
very excited to be
working with TFL to
bring this to Londoners
who are using Android Pay.
That's the first thing.
The second cool feature is today
when you forget to tap out,
unfortunately what has to
happen is-- and by the way just
to confirm what
I mean, tap out--
as you enter your journey
you have to tap in,
as I just demonstrated.
But as you exit, you
have to usually tap out.
Sometimes folks who are in
a hurry, forget to tap out.
And they might get charged the
maximum amount for the day.
Now we've solved the problem
for both users and for TFL.
And you can see that I had
taken them a bunch of rides
while I was there
over the weekend.
And I forgot to tap out
for one of them on purpose.
And I got a notification
from Android Pay,
and I don't know
whether you can see it.
Oh, it is a little white.
So I'm going to try to
tilt it a little bit.
Can you see that now?
perfect so I have
a notification that
reminds me to tap out and
complete my journey so I
can avoid the maximum fare.
It's really awesome for users,
and really awesome for TFL
as well.
So very, very exciting.
[APPLAUSE]
SRIDHAR RAMASWAMY:
For those of us
that have had a Hillary
Clinton moment in New York City
subways, this is
a welcome change.
PALI BHAT: So I've set
up Android Pay right when
we launched last September.
And I've had my Bank of America
Visa card in Android Pay.
I'm a Bank of America customer.
And I've had my Bank of America
Visa debit card in Android Pay
and I have used it for
all kinds of purchases.
The one thing I've
never been able to do
with my Bank of
America Visa debit card
is get cash at an ATM.
But that's changed.
Because we've partnered
with Bank of America.
And to tell us more
is Michelle Moore,
the Head of Digital
Banking at Bank of America.
Michelle.
MICHELLE MOORE: Thank you.
Thank you, Pali.
We're really excited
to be here today.
And excited to be a
partner with Android Pay.
Bank of America is
committed to our clients
to make their financial lives
simple, easy, and secure.
And to do just that,
we've heard your feedback.
And we have built, with
Android Pay, the ability
to withdraw cash at an ATM.
And you can actually
do it live today
across 650 ATMs in the Silicon
Valley and San Francisco area.
[APPLAUSE]
By the end of this month,
we'll be live on 2,400 ATMs.
And by the end of
this year, 5,000 ATMs.
So why don't we take a
walk over to the ATM,
and see this in action?
PALI BHAT: Awesome.
Look forward to seeing it.
MICHELLE MOORE: So I figured
I would take out $20,
and maybe you can buy me one
of these Android Pay shirts.
PALI BHAT: Only cost
like 9 bucks, Michelle,
so we'll send you two.
MICHELLE MOORE: We'll have two.
Thank you.
OK.
It's as easy as holding the
phone next to the reader.
It's read the Android Pay.
It's asking me for my pin
number like it normally
should for security purposes.
So I'll enter in my pin.
$20-- you'll buy
me two t-shirts.
Excellent.
Just what I always wanted.
And here we go.
Live now.
Here you go.
[APPLAUSE]
It's that simple.
No more reason to carry around
your debit card or your credit
card.
PALI BHAT: But Michelle,
it's only 16 bucks.
MICHELLE MOORE: You
can keep the change.
PALI BHAT: Well, thank you.
MICHELLE MOORE: Awesome.
PALI BHAT: It's a pleasure.
MICHELLE MOORE: Thank you.
PALI BHAT: So we're
super excited.
Thank you for the partnership.
And I look forward to using
this at an ATM really close by.
And if you guys are in the San
Francisco area for a little bit
longer, take advantage of this.
Go try it out at an at a
Bank of America ATM near you.
OK.
MICHELLE MOORE: Right.
Thank you.
PALI BHAT: Thank you, Michelle.
So you saw a couple of the use
cases for using Android Pay.
New use cases-- you saw of
course, the journey on TFL,
and you saw the cash withdrawals
at the Bank of America ATM.
So now, I want to talk
to you about one more
feature that we're building
in partnership with all
of our merchants.
And that's the ability
to save money as well.
We already save you time.
And it's convenient.
But what if you could
save your money too?
And to do that, what I
want to showcase with you
is the experience that
we've built with Walgreens.
It's available to
all our merchant
partners, using
an open API again.
But we're really
thrilled about what
we've built with Walgreens.
So let me grab one
of these phones here,
and we can go back
to the Wolf Vision.
Let me grab both of the phones.
Because I'm going to
show you two different
experiences, and we're
very excited about it.
Can we cut to the Wolf
Vision if you don't mind?
OK wonderful.
So we have-- we
have the phone up.
And before I actually
dive into the demo,
I just want to ask
you a question.
How many of you have signed
up for a loyalty card
but forgot to use it
when you're in the store?
It's quite a few of us, right?
And so we figured we'd
work with the Walgreens
to help you save the
card to Android Pay
so we can automatically
use it at checkout.
So that we can
remember it for you,
and you never have to lose
any more points again.
Now there's two ways to do this.
The first way of course is
if I'm an existing member.
You remember I told you
had a seven-year-old kid?
Means I'm a frequent
Walgreen's customer.
OK?
I go there all the time.
And I've signed up for
Balance Awards, which
is an amazing loyalty program.
And so if you're an
existing user like me,
Walgreens can just send
you an e-mail, or an sms,
or even have a
button on their site
that lets you just save the
Balance Rewards card to Android
Pay with just one touch.
So let me just show it
to you within an e-mail.
So I got an e-mail
from Walgreens,
and they're giving me an offer
to save this Balance Reward
card to Android Pay.
And I'm just going to
do that by touching it.
And it's that simple.
OK?
Balance Rewards card
saved to Android Pay.
[APPLAUSE]
And it's telling you that all I
need to do to use this, is tap
and I'm set.
OK?
Very, very exciting.
But then what if you're
not a member already?
So we decided to build an
amazing experience for that
as well.
So I'm going to show you an
experience with an Android Pay.
OK?
Sorry.
Let me get this up.
Turns out that I've paid at
Walgreens with my AmEx card
with an Android Pay.
And I have a receipt from
Walgreens already in this app.
So we open up the receipt.
It shows me an amazingly
helpful receipt
which has the map, the
exact location where
I made this purchase.
And a personalized
message from Walgreens
that lets me sign up for
the Balance Rewards card.
So I'm going to
touch "Signup here."
And notice that all my
information is already
filled OK?
So no typing at all.
I'm going to transfer and share
this information to Walgreens.
OK?
Everything is filled in again.
All I have to do is
type in a password,
which I'm going to do now.
Submit.
Save And I'm a new
Balance Rewards member.
So very, very cool.
And again, it's as
simple as tapping
on a Walgreen's terminal in
order to use this Balance
Rewards card.
So we've made the experience
really, really simple.
And it's available to
all merchants as well.
But let's go and try to
complete this purchase here
and show you what the
experience looks like.
So we have here a terminal.
Can we switch this?
We have here a terminal.
This is an actual
Walgreens terminal.
OK?
And we're going to
show you what it's
like to make a purchase of one
of these, really nice, like,
almonds.
OK?
Turns out it
normally costs $5.99.
Vinnie, can you just focus
in a little bit closer on it
so that maybe you can
actually see the charge?
OK.
So I think you notice it.
Right?
It's $5.99 except that that's
just the regular price.
If you have a
Balance Rewards card,
you get a price break on
this, which is very cool.
Helps you save money.
OK?
So what I'm going
to do is show you
how easy it is to use
your Balance Rewards
card with Android Pay.
So look at my phone.
Again, I don't need
to open the app.
There's a consistent theme--
I don't have to open up
Android Pay to use it, etc.
I'm just going to tap.
I've transferred my
Balance Rewards card.
That's simple.
And I've got a price break.
And the new price is $3.99.
And to complete this
purchase, all I have to do
is tap again, transfer my
AmEx, and the purchase is done.
OK?
[APPLAUSE]
We are very excited
about this experience.
So look forward to seeing
more merchants integrate
to this experience
so that you can
engage your customers better,
and your customers get
to save money.
So with that, I want to
hand over to Sridhar.
SRIDHAR RAMASWAMY:
Thank you, Pali.
These are some
amazing demos, again.
Of course, we wanted to make
sure that we did something
for small- and medium-sized
merchants as well.
So we worked with Square to make
available for a limited time
to qualified retailers,
a free contactless reader
as well as discounted payment
processing on all Android Pay
transactions.
We want to make sure that all
merchants get benefit then
consumers use
Android Pay to pay.
I want to touch on something
really, really important.
It is the last portion of our
talk, but it's super critical.
It hits many of the points
that I talked about earlier.
It's clear that financial
institutions-- the ones
that we have our credit,
debit, all these relationships
with-- need to
play an active role
in moving the mobile
payment ecosystem forward.
And when we envisioned
Android Pay,
we created APIs that
these banks could
use to bring the
payment experience
right within their app.
Why is this a big deal?
Because there's a lot of
detail to implementing
a great payments experience.
And they could integrate
it right into their app,
saving themselves a lot of
implementation headaches,
security headaches,
and of course time--
which is the most
important currency.
And they do that, then they're
free to innovate on what else
they offer their consumers.
These banks are often the
ones that know us best.
They're the ones that are
observing our transactions.
You know, they're the ones that
we have our relationships with.
We think this will drive
a lot of innovation
in how mobile payments are
brought out to consumers.
So we're very pleased
that a number of banks
both in the US and
abroad, are working
with us to integrate Android
Pay directly into their app.
We think this will
drive more innovation
and provide more
flexibility for consumers.
We think of this as a
win-win for Android,
Android Pay and for
you know, these banks
and of course consumers as well.
And with that, now
I want to thank
all of you, our
developer partners,
in bringing this
Android story forward.
Without us working
together, there's
not going to be a
lot of innovation.
And so we really look to
working with you to improve
the way mobile payments work.
So for us to get past the
which-pay-is-doing-what
and more, to mobile payments
just work in a way that is
expected, and convenient
for all of us.
So thanks to all of
you who are helping us
realize this vision
of Android Pay being
everywhere-- in mobile apps, in
physical stores, in mobile web
as well.
So Pali and I have
barely touched
on the surface of topics
that can literally
take days of discussion.
We're going to be having
lots of breakout sessions
over the next two days
and I think one right
after this session.
PALI BHAT: The one
right after this.
SRIDHAR RAMASWAMY: Right here.
And so please attend those.
Please ask us lots of questions.
They'll be folks from
the payments team in all
of these breakout sessions.
We look forward to
talking with you,
and really helping bring
this vision of Android
Pay to the larger world.
And with that, thank
you all for coming.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]